let's say that this circle right over
here represents one one hole and we've
divided this circle into 1 2 3 4 5 equal
sections so each of these sections
represents one-fifth each of these each
of these sections represents one-fifth
of the circle and we've seen this
already 1/5 1/5 1/5 and 1/5 and if we
were to then color in some of this so
let's say we're coloring 3 of these
sections so that's one of those sections
right over there another one right over
here
so we've colored in two of the fifths
and then three of the fish notice you
put those 3 1/5 together how much have
we now shaded in we've shaded in 3/5 of
the whole so the fraction that's
actually shaded in now is 3 3/5 fifths
3/5 is what's shaded in now let's do
something in some ways a little bit
simpler but also in some ways kind of
interesting let's start with a hole
again so once again this is one hole let
me label it one hole so it's one hole
and instead of dividing it into five
equal sections I'm just going to divide
it into one equal section so if I were
to shade in if I were to shade this in
so if I were to shade it in just like
that so I'm shading in my one hole I'm
shading in my one equal section how many
of the equal sections are now shaded in
well just to remind ourselves there is
one equal section and I have shaded in
exactly one of those one equal section
I've shaded in the whole thing or I
could say that 1/1 which you'll never
hear someone actually say is shaded in
or I could say that the whole thing is
shaded in so this is equal to one whole
so that's a whole that's interesting and
I want you to keep in mind remember look
we have 3 we literally have 1 2 3 fifths
and we literally call that three-fifths
now this is one hole now what happens if
we were to do this multiple times so if
we were to let me copy and paste that so
now
I have another one hole and then another
one hole right over here so now in total
how many holes do I have well I have
three one two three holes so I could say
and I've actually shaded in three holes
so this is this one right over here is
equal to let me make sure I label it
right this right over here is equal to
if I were to take the combination this
is equal to three three holes or if I
were to think of in terms of numbers
just the number line this is literally
this would represent the number three
but what's another way I could represent
it notice when I took a 1/5 another 1/5
and another 1/5 I could call that 3/5 so
now if I take 1 1 1 1 another 1 1 and
another 1 1 well I should be able to
call this 3 3 once or 3 first or however
you want to call it so I could call this
3 first so this is interesting now we're
seeing where the top number on a
fraction is larger than the bottom one
but another way of thinking about this
fraction symbol is that it's division so
you could view this as 3 divided by 1 is
equal to 3 or you could say well like 1
over 1 is a whole and I now have 3 of
them so this is equal to 3 wholes so 3
over 1 is the same thing as the number 3
and let me make sure let me emphasize
that let me draw this on a number line
so once again let me let me go all the
way to 3 so 0 1 2 & 3 so one whole gets
us exactly 1 jump on the number line so
this right over here that gets us to 1
over 1 we do another jump now we've
gotten to first I guess you could say
we've essentially taken two of these
jumps each jump is 1 over 1 now we are 2
over 1 which is the same thing as 2 you
take another jump you take another jump
and we essentially get 2 or we do get 2
3 over 1 which is the exact same thing
as 3